et si on est sur le chantier du projet
serendipity
c'est ni plus ni moins que la plus
importante opération de logement
étudiant actuellement en cours en france
dans un peu plus d'un an donc en
septembre 2017
on aurait ici plus de mille étudiants
qui habiteront au coeur du quartier de
moulon dans le campus urbain paris
saclay c'est un projet qui a été
développé par link site ile de france
qui a été désigné en avril 2014 par le
pea paris saclay nous ce qu'on a cherché
dès le départ dans ce projet c'est de
créer le meilleur cadre de vie possible
pour les étudiants qui habiteront ici
donc pour ça on s'est entouré des deux
des meilleures agences d'architecturé
françaises lan architecture et clément
vergély architectes qui ont développé un
parti pris un bain chaud lecture halles
qui s'inscrit dans là dans la trame qui
avaient été définis par l'urbanisme
michel desvigne ainsi que c'est en menus
et au mas qui est de créer un véritable
parc paysager habiter un parent qui
vient apporter 100 bâtiments cylindrique
qui représente sur leurs façades les
muses de l'antiquité sur serendipity on
a cherché à répondre à la diversité des
modes de vie des étudiants en proposant
différentes typologies premièrement bon
le studio classique le t1 étudiants
également les colocations sont de 2,2 et
2,3 personnes qui sont dans des
proportions assez importante pour un
programme étudiants qui sont à 30% de
colocation et enfin dernière typologie
innovante le t1 grappes
c'est en fait un studio qui conserve sa
kitchenette et salle de bains mais qui
partage est ce qu'on appelle un salon de
grappes c'est à dire une salle commune à
12 à 16 studios
on a voulu vraiment dans cette résidence
cueillez de la vie l'animation est que
ce soit pas la cage à lapins
étudiante
qu'on a pu malheureusement faire dans le
passé vraiment créer un campus qui
répondent à la haute ambition du campus
paris saclay on a eu un défi très claire
dès qu'on a été désigné le mois de mai
on a monté le projet développé ce projet
dans un temps record avec l'aménageur
les collectivités locales
nos architectes paysagistes pour tenir
ce démarrage du chantier qui a démarré
en décembre 2015 donc pour 20 mois de
chantier et aujourd'hui on est tout à
fait dans les temps on sera prêt pour la
rentrée septembre 2017 et c'est avec
grand plaisir qu'on accueillera les
étudiants de centrale ici à la rentrée
des misères